.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Und, nervös?
- Und wie.
Aber er auch. Das ist das Geniale.
Das ist die Geschichte
von Béatrice Steiner,
die es gewagt hat,
aus Liebe zu Windhunden
ihre gut bezahlte Managerstelle
in der Schweiz aufzugeben,
um ausgerechnet auf Hunderennbahnen
in Irland ihr Glück zu suchen.
* Flache, rasante Musik *
* Stimmengewirr, Anfeuerungsrufe *
* Ein Kommentator
wird von der Musik übertönt. *
* Hunde bellen und heulen. *
Wollt ihr raus? Hm? Ja.
Wo wollen wir das hintun?
Ja, warten, warten, warten! So.
So.
Windhunderennen
haben in Irland Tradition.
Seit bald 100 Jahren
lassen die Iren ihre Hunde auf
Rennbahnen gegeneinander antreten.
Niemand hat darauf gewartet,
dass eine Frau, noch dazu
eine Ausländerin, da mitmischt.
Doch seit sieben Jahren
tut Béatrice Steiner genau das.
Auf ihrem Hof bei Cavan
unweit der nordirischen Grenze
lebt sie mit 80 Windhunden ―
eigenen und solchen,
die sie für Kunden züchtet,
aufzieht, schult und trainiert.
Langsam! Hey!
Das kommt bei den alteingesessenen
Iren nicht immer gut an.
Am Anfang wird man natürlich total
als Exot betrachtet
und nicht ernst genommen.
Die denken:
"In einem Jahr sind die wieder weg."
Das hier
haben ja auch schon einige versucht.
Also, kein Schweizer
ist sehr lange geblieben.
Es gibt hier ein paar Deutsche, aber
die meisten haben wieder aufgehört -
einfach, weil ...
Hier herrscht halt
eine komplett andere Kultur.
Es ist ...
Man wird nicht ernst genommen.
Es ist ja
eine grosse Bevölkerungsgruppe,
die Greyhound-Rennen macht.
Die sind seit ... ihrer Kindheit
miteinander befreundet.
Es ist wirklich schwierig,
reinzukommen.
Statt mit Einheimischen
beschäftigt sich die 48-Jährige
lieber mit ihren Hunden.
Einer ihrer grossen Hoffnungsträger
ist Swissjet.
Er gehört
einer Gruppe von Schweizern,
dem Team-Swiss-Syndicate,
und hat einen Marktwert von 4'000 Fr.
Diesen wird Swissjet in wenigen Tagen
am grössten Rennen des Landes
verteidigen müssen.
Für Steiner ist es nicht nur eine
Frage von gewinnen oder verlieren,
sondern auch
eine Herzensangelegenheit.
Wenn ich ihn an den Start bringe
und Parade ist,
und jeder Hund
wird einzeln vorgestellt ...
Wenn ich dann höre:
"Besitzer: Team-Swiss-Syndicate",
bin ich natürlich schon stolz.
Ich höre das irgendwie gerne.
Ich bin durchaus
durch und durch Schweizerin.
Ich bin
wegen Greyhound-Rennen in Irland,
nicht wirklich
wegen des Landes und der Leute.
Das ist letzten Endes auch ...
Man zieht wegen eines Jobs
in ein Land,
und wenn man dann
als Schweizerin wahrgenommen wird
und die Schweiz
am Rennen repräsentieren darf,
hat man einen gewissen Stolz, ja.
Bist du ein Swiss? Hm?
Für Steiner stand die Wahl ihres
Auswanderungslandes ausser Frage.
Aus Irland
kommen die schnellsten Windhunde.
Der beste Ort für sie, ihre
Ambitionen in Erfolg zu verwandeln.
Natalie Abedi ist
Béatrice Steiners Lebenspartnerin.
Gemeinsam führen sie den Hof.
Der Trainer kommt mit Essen.
Kommt mal her!
Habt ihr Hunger,
ihr kleinen Scheisser?
* Natalie macht Kussgeräusche. *
Danke.
So, nicht streiten!
Jeder kriegt was.
Nein, aufhören jetzt! Lieb sein!
Die 38-jährige Fotografin
aus Darmstadt
hat sich schon als Jugendliche
in Windhunde verliebt.
Die zwei Frauen
kannten sich gerade mal drei Monate,
als sie hierher in die Fremde zogen.
Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Ich hab für jeden was dabei.
Chippy, komm her! Komm!
Hier ist dein Napf.
Du hast pink. Komm her, Baby!
Nein, du bist Judo. Du weisst,
du darfst da gar nicht essen.
Darfst du da gar nicht essen?
Chippy, du bleibst hier. Auf geht's!
Die stehen so auf die Pute.
Die nehmen dir das aus dem Eimer,
bevor du es ausschüttest.
Wobei, die einen da oben
waren nicht so hungrig.
Casey und Old?
- Nein, Salomon.
Hier?
- Ja.
Wenn du wüsstest,
was die gefrühstückt haben.
Ich züchte sie,
ich setze sie in die Welt,
ich bin ab der ersten Lebensminute
bei den Kleinen.
Und ab einem bestimmten Punkt
übergebe ich sie ihr ganz bewusst.
Wegen der Art und Weise, wie sie
dann mit diesen Geschöpfen umgeht,
wachsen meine Liebe
und mein Respekt immer mehr,
weil es einfach
so wahnsinnig viel Sinn macht
und so wahnsinnig schön ist.
Erstaunlicherweise sorgt die
Beziehung zwischen den beiden Frauen
im erzkatholisch-konservativen Irland
kaum für Reaktionen.
Für die Leute hier sei das
schlicht kein Thema, sagen sie.
Essenszeit! Kommt mal her!
Du bist ein Baby, ja.
So, auf geht's! Nein, alle essen.
Mama kommt gleich wieder.
Eine ausländische Frau,
die ihren Platz in einer
männerdominierten Welt reklamiert,
das hat hingegen
durchaus Gerede verursacht.
Gewisse Trainer haben Béatrice
Steiner direkt ins Gesicht gesagt,
was sie davon halten.
Stewart war mal auf dem Platz.
Wir sprachen miteinander,
und er sagte:
"Only the Irish men
can train a greyhound."
Ja, da wusste ich es.
- Wie lange warst du da hier?
Eine Woche?
- Ja. Oder einen Monat.
Hat dich schwer beeindruckt, oder?
- Ja, schwer beeindruckt.
Ja, wir haben schon
unsere Herausforderungen hier.
Richtig angekommen bist du erst,
wenn du eins dieser
ganz dicken Dinger gewonnen hast -
in den Augen der Iren. Für uns ist
alles gut. Wir sind sowieso happy.
Aber hier geht's nur ums Gewinnen.
Nicht?
- Mhm.
Zweiter oder Dritter ...
- ... ist uninteressant.
Du musst siegen. Das ist nicht ganz
so das, was wir im Auge haben.
Um den Sieg ging's schon
in Steiners früherem Leben.
Bevor die Maschinenbau- und
Betriebswirtschafsingenieurin
mit 41 ihren Aussteigertraum
verwirklichte, hatte sie jahrelang
im Kader verschiedener Medizinal-
technikunternehmen gearbeitet.
Auch damals
zählten nur Topleistungen.
Vermissen Sie manchmal den Alltag,
den Sie in der Schweiz hatten?
Wenn ich bis auf
die Unterhose nass bin, dann schon.
Aber sonst gar nicht.
Jetzt bin ich für die Hunde
und mich verantwortlich
und kann das so machen,
wie ich es für richtig halte.
Und ich kann
das Beste daraus machen.
Als Manager ist es
je länger, desto schwieriger,
weil man nicht nur
für die Leute zuständig ist.
Man muss auch das Management ...
... bzw. die Chefetage
glücklich machen.
Das ist halt ...
... nicht mehr so einfach,
besonders wenn die Zahlen
halt nicht stetig nach oben zeigen.
Und hier ...
ist mir das eigentlich egal,
solange ich etwas zu essen habe
und die Hunde ernähren kann.
* Ruhige, friedliche Gitarrenklänge *
* Er lacht. *
Für die Managerin
gab es nur einen Weg zum Glück:
weg von Grosskonzernen hin zu einem
ehrlichen und bodenständigen Leben
in einer Umgebung, die der Hunde-
trainerin schon immer mehr lag
als die Teppichetage.
Good morning. How are you?
- I'm good. How are you?
Hast du Ferien geplant?
Ich reise nächste Woche
in die Schweiz.
Meine Mutter hat Geburtstag.
Schön.
Wie ist das Wetter da?
Sehr warm.
- Yeah?
Zu warm für uns.
Okay, lovely.
- Alright, thank you very much.
Thank you. Take care, bye!
Es sind die Traineraufträge,
mit denen sich Steiner
einen Namen macht.
Das Geld bringen aber
Zucht und Schulung der Hunde.
In den ersten Jahren
ist deshalb viel Erspartes
in den grossen Traum geflossen.
Seit einem Jahr
trägt sich der Hof nun selbst.
Viel Geld für Luxus
bleibt trotzdem nicht.
Ist das reduzierte Leben für Sie ein
Gewinn oder z.T. auch ein Verlust?
Also, das ist für mich
so eine Momentanblende.
Ich denke nicht,
dass es für immer so sein wird.
Darum ist es für mich ein Gewinn,
weil ich denke,
dass ich dieses ganz einfache Leben
wahrscheinlich nie mehr haben werde.
Dass man noch
mit Kohle oder Holz heizt,
dass man für warmes Wasser erst
den Schalter drehen und warten muss,
bis es aufgeheizt ist.
Dass man jeden Schritt
irgendwie planen muss.
Hundefreie Momente
sind für die Frauen überaus selten -
noch, denn irgendwann
soll auch wieder mehr Zeit
für die Partnerschaft bleiben,
und zwar abseits vom Hundegebell.
Feld, Wiese, Rennbahn
und manchmal sogar Drehkreuz:
Steiner musste erfinderisch werden,
um all ihre Hunde auf Trab zu halten.
Mit verschiedenen Trainingsmethoden
und frischem Futter,
das mit Vitaminen,
Fetten und Ölen ergänzt wird,
bringt sie ihre Hunde
zu Bestleistungen.
Letztlich gehört aber auch bei Tieren
ein Talent für den Rennsport dazu -
ein angeborenes Gewinner-Gen.
Die Pflege der Tiere
setzt Wissen voraus.
Steiner hat es sich durch ihre
Ausbildung zur Orthopädistin
und spezialisierte Seminare
angeeignet.
Es sind aber v.a.
die 25 Jahre Erfahrung,
dank derer sie
jede atypische Bewegung des Hundes
und jedes schräge Bellen
sofort deuten kann.
Ja, das tut nicht weh.
Ich behandle ihn hier
mit ultrasound.
Er hat sich auf der Wiese
den Fuss umgeknickt.
Es ist also keine Rennverletzung.
Er ist ein kleiner Hibbelfrosch.
Aber ...
Auch das schaffen wir, Tommy, nicht?
Dann kannst du wieder reingehen.
Komm! So.
Das sind recht kleine Anlagen.
Ist das nicht etwas klein
für einen so grossen Hund?
Er schläft hier nur.
Sie sind da Katzen ähnlich:
Sie schlafen 20 Std.,
und in den 4 Std., in denen sie
wach sind, wollen sie Action.
Da wollen sie was tun, sie wollen
was erleben, da muss etwas los sein.
* Rap aus dem Radio:
"Holunder" von Steff la Cheffe *
Steiner ist überzeugt,
dass ihre Hunde am besten
mit Schweizer Radio im Hintergrund
entspannen können.
(Frau im Radio)
Steff la Cheffe mit "Holunder".
Hier auf SRF 3 gibt's jetzt ...
* Sphärische Musik *
Kommerzielle Windhunderennen
sind weltweit
nur noch in acht Ländern erlaubt.
Eine Szene ist in Irland
immer häufiger anzutreffen:
aufgebrachte Gruppen
von Tierschützern,
die Windhunderennen
aufs Schärfste verurteilen
und als Schande brandmarken.
Angeprangert werden
Überzüchtung, Tierquälerei
und die grausame Ermordung
jener Hunde,
die ihre Leistung nicht
oder nicht mehr erbringen.
(Alle) Shame, shame, shame on you!
Shame, shame, shame on you!
(Frau) Abusive! Shame on you!
Shame on you!
Shame, shame, shame on you!
Ich will, dass Windhunderennen
in Irland verboten werden.
Komplett, zu 100 %. Es ist falsch!
Diese Industrie basiert
auf einem Modell von Überzüchtung.
Man züchtet zu viele Windhunde,
wählt die Besten aus
und entsorgt die anderen.
Sie nennen sie Abfall.
Wir holen Windhunde
aus China und Bangladesch zurück.
In diese Länder werden sie nach dem
Ende ihrer Rennkarriere exportiert.
Dort werden sie für die Zucht
genutzt, bis sie fast tot sind.
Manche enden sogar im Fleischhandel.
* Sphärische Musik *
Steiner spürt Gegenwind
nicht bloss seitens
der männerdominierten Branche.
Sie muss auch
gegen den schlechten Ruf ankämpfen,
den der Hundesport hat.
Wie ist es,
mit Buhrufen und "Shame on you"
zu einem Rennen empfangen zu werden?
Es ist wie ein Schlag ins Gesicht.
Nicht etwas,
über das man sich freut.
Man fühlt sich
ein wenig angegriffen.
Die Demonstranten sagen,
es gebe bei Greyhounds nur den Sieg
oder umgebracht zu werden.
Haben sie recht?
- Überhaupt nicht, nein.
Der Hund rennt,
weil er das
im Adrenalin hat, im Blut.
Er will rennen.
Einen Verlierer
gibt es demzufolge nicht.
Jeder Hund, der ins Ziel kommt,
wird sagen, er sei ein Gewinner.
Er habe sich darüber gefreut.
Wenn die Hunde älter werden,
ihre wilden Jahre vorbei sind,
suchen Steiner und Partnerin Natalie
ihnen einen Platz als Haustier.
Für sie, die Hunde lieben,
ist es selbstverständlich,
dafür zu sorgen, dass es den Hunden
in einem neuen Daheim gut geht.
Und so vermitteln sie Plätze
nicht nur für ihre eigenen,
sondern auch für Hunde
anderer Trainer.
Macht die Branche etwas falsch,
dass das offenbar so rüberkommt?
Ja, das ist sicher auch so.
Es ist halt immer an beiden Seiten,
Fehler zu finden und zu suchen.
Die Antis haben Schlagwörter,
die auch irgendwie reinhauen.
Wenn man versucht,
sich zu rechtfertigen,
oder wenn man wütend wird,
hat das ja auch keinen Sinn.
Man muss versuchen,
die guten Seiten vorzuleben,
und vielleicht halt eben auch
die Türen öffnen und zeigen,
wie man die Hunde behandelt
und was wir alles tun,
sodass so ein Schlagwort
gar keinen Einfluss mehr haben kann.
Béatrice Steiner ist unerschrocken,
wenn es darum geht,
Missstände in der eigenen Branche
anzuprangern,
und sie zeigt schwarze Schafe
ohne Zögern
beim nationalen Verband
für Windhundsport an.
* Energetische Gitarrenmusik *
Komm!
Beim Wegzug in die Fremde ist es
ein bisschen wie auf dem Rennplatz.
Gewinn und Niederlage liegen manchmal
bedrohlich nahe beieinander.
Die Liebe zu den Tieren
war das Risiko wert,
auch wenn Steiner dafür
viel aufgegeben musste.
Ich habe sehr viel zurückgelassen.
Ich habe Familie und Freunde
zurückgelassen,
ich habe einen Ort zurückgelassen,
an dem ich mich wohlgefühlt habe,
in dem ich mich bewegt habe
und von dem ich gewusst habe,
wie ich mich zu verhalten hatte.
Ich habe meine Heimat
zurückgelassen.
Ich bin einfach
als Béatrice hergekommen.
Man wusste nichts über mich,
und es interessierte auch keinen.
Ich musste mich erst bestätigen.
Inzwischen ist ganz klar,
dass Béatrice
hier Greyhoundtrainerin ist.
Sie gehört
zu den Shelbourne-Park-Trainern,
sie gehört zu
den ersten 25 Trainern.
Man nimmt mich
doch auch ernst, also ...
... man verfolgt meine Hunde
und schaut,
welche Resultate sie erreicht haben.
Man gratuliert mir.
Man nimmt mich auf jeden Fall wahr.
Die Umgebung mag sich zwar
grundlegend verändert haben,
Steiner jedoch nicht.
Sie lebt noch immer für ihren Beruf.
Statt zahlenbesessener Konzernbosse
diktieren nun allerdings die Hunde
ihren Alltag.
Egal ob beim Spaziergang,
beim Kochen, Rennen oder Fernsehen:
Seit bald 30 Jahren sieht man Steiner
kaum je ohne Windhund an ihrer Seite.
Der Greyhound ist mein Lebensinhalt.
Ich bin gerne für den Hund da, aber
er gibt mir auch wahnsinnig viel.
Er erfüllt mich.
Ich möchte, dass er sich möglichst
in seinem Naturell entwickelt
und uns letzten Endes
auch zeigen kann, was in ihm steckt.
Finaltag. Das grosse Rennen
im Shelbourne Park, Dublin,
dem wichtigsten Rennplatz des Landes.
Wer hier gewinnt, ist jemand.
Hallo!
Dreieinhalb Jahre Aufzucht,
Dutzende Stunden Training:
Hat sich die harte Arbeit gelohnt?
Wird es ihr Swissjet
aufs Siegertreppchen schaffen?
(Mann) Swissjet!
- Yes.
70 pounds. Great, thank you.
Ich muss schnell bezahlen.
* Fliessende, drängende Musik *
Heute geht es um Ruhm und Ehre,
ein Preisgeld von 2'500 Fr.,
v.a. aber um die Frage,
ob auch eine Frau und Ausländerin
einen Windhund
zum Champion trainieren kann.
* Unverständliche
Lautsprecherdurchsage *
Black Marble Sky, yes!
So, jetzt können wir
nichts mehr tun - nur hoffen.
* Fliessende, drängende Musik *
* Unverständliche Durchsage *
Nervös?
- Und wie.
Jetzt fängt's ... zu früh! Nein!
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Gut! Gute Positionen!
* Durchsage, Anfeuerungsrufe *
Die Eins ist schneller. Das war
zu vermuten. Aber er kann ...
... er kann sich
wenigstens in Szene setzen.
Dritte Kurve, ziemlich eng.
Er geht weit, wie immer,
um Schwung zu holen.
Und jetzt nach Hause!
Komm, komm, komm, komm!
Zweiter! Super!
Nur wenige Millisekunden
am Sieg vorbei. 450 Fr. Preisgeld.
(Mann) Yes!
(Zweiter Mann) Come here!
Come here! Here!
Eine solide Leistung,
die Steiner und die Schweizer
Besitzer von Swissjet stolz macht.
Und, zufrieden?
- Super! Genial!
Es hätte nicht besser sein können.
Bei dieser Konkurrenz Zweiter -
super!
Gut gestartet. Gesund.
Spass gehabt. Alles genial.
Ich habe immer Mühe,
ihm den Maulkorb
und die Renndecke abzunehmen,
weil ich irgendwie fast stärker
ausser Atem bin als der Hund.
Einfach wegen der ganzen Aufregung
und des Adrenalinkicks.
Es ist schon Wahnsinn.
Na? Ja, okay.
Glück, das ist für Béatrice Steiner
immer wieder ein schneller Hund.
Dabei muss er gar nicht
der schnellste im Rennen sein.
* Schnelle, positive Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2019